today what we're gonna do is continue
our discussion of factor markets by
essentially talking about how capital
markets impact real-world decisions so
last time we talked about the capital
market we talked about essentially the
way that firms finance their capital is
by going to a pool of savings that
individuals decide and how much to make
individuals make an inter temporal
choice on how much to save actually
technically make an internal choice
about how much to consume each period
that then yields an amount of savings
and then based on that pool of savings
firms borrow with some interest rate I
and they decide how much to invest now
today we're going to talk about a number
of interesting applications that arise
from capital markets that are important
in the real world I'm going to start by
talking about the concept of present
value present value now the key insight
when we think about capital markets is
that a dollar tomorrow is worth less
than a dollar today a dollar tomorrow is
worth less than dollars a that's because
if you had the dollar today you could
productively invest it and have more
than a dollar tomorrow so in Davos a is
worth more because you could do
something productive with that dollar if
you had it today okay what that means is
that dollars in different periods are
worth different things you can't just
add them up
okay the analogy I like is thinking
about imagine you had a pound of apples
a pound of steak and a pound of gold you
wouldn't just add them up and say I have
three pounds that'd be useless you'd
want to know what each is worth it you
want to add up the dollar value of them
okay it's a similar thing with money
received over time you can't just say
I'm getting a dollar today a dollar next
year and a dollar five years from now
they aren't the same thing
money received at different points of
time or worth different amounts because
money received in the future forgoes the
possibility of investing it today okay
so what do we do to deal with this well
in economics we deal with this bike the
concept of present value present value
is the value of every periods payment
in terms of today so the way we deal
with the fact that money different
parents worth different amounts is by
what we call discounting it back to
today we said so take future dollars and
dip it discount them back to today to
get present value we discount them
because future dollars are worthless
okay so let's think of it this way
suppose that um the interest rate is 10
percent let students they have imagine
the interest rate I is 10 percent and
let's say that you want to have 100
dollars next year you want your you want
next year you want to have 100 dollars
well how much do you have to put in the
bank today okay well we could solve the
equation which is that you want the
amount you put in the bank today let's
call that Y times 1 plus the interest
rate because that's what you make by
having the bank equal to 100 that's
equation we want to solve right the
money you've bout you put in today y
times 1 plus the interest rate you want
that to be equal to 100 so what that
says is that y equals 90 point nine if
you put $90.90
in the bank today at a 10 percent
interest rate you will have $100
tomorrow more generally we say that the
present value of any future payment it's
the future value the amount you get in
the future over 1 plus I to the power
little T where T is the periods in the
future so money received t periods in
the future today is worth the amount you
get in the future over 1 plus I to the T
okay so that is our general formula for
how we think about present value take
all the future payments and you discount
them back today by dividing by 1 call
side of the T now that works well if
there's a future payment in one future
payment coming but what if as in many
cases is the whole stream of future
payments coming well the logic then is
the same you just want to take each
future payment and discount it by how
far it is in the future
okay so suppose that you say um that you
want me to loan you $30 and that you'll
pay me back $10 each of the next three
years okay
and suppose the interest rates 10% well
I will say no to that because I will say
if you're gonna pay me back $10 each of
the next three years then what is it
what's the present value of that the
present value is next year's $10 over
1.1 because the interest rate is 10%
plus the $10 a year after that over 1.1
squared plus the $10 the year after that
over 1.1 cubed which way if I add it up
is 24 87 so I am losing money if I if I
give you $30 today and if you give me
$10 back each of the next three years
I'm losing money why because if I had
simply taken that money and invested in
the bank I would have had a lot more
than the $30 I'm gonna get for you after
three years okay so the money that comes
in the future must be discounted back to
today that's the key inside of present
value you can't just add it up you've
got to put it in today's terms by
discounting it by the interest rate and
how far it for future yeah
we're assuming now inflation zero so
we're assuming right now we're not doing
with inflation we're assuming a world
where prices don't change we'll come
back to inflation in a few minutes but
for now just assume that prices don't
change okay so basically arm essentially
the formula then for the present value
your general formula for present value
you need to know is the present value
equals present value equals if you get a
flat stream of payment F for a number of
periods it's f times 1 over 1 plus I to
the T plus 1 I'm sorry 1 over 1 plus I
to the 1 plus 1 over 1 plus I squared
plus 1 over 1 plus I cubed plus not that
up at the top for how many periods you
get it so if you're getting a payment F
over a certain number of periods
you've got to discount it by how many
periods you're gonna get it okay
or more generally a common formula will
ask you to use in this class is to think
about the formula for a perpetuity a
perpetuity is a flat payment you get
forever so if we think the infinite sum
of this equation we can summarize it as
present value approximately equals F
over the interest rate so if I promise
you to pay you forever a certain amount
F that is worth F over the interest rate
so in other words if each rates 10% a
promise to pay you $10 forever is worth
about a hundred bucks that's the rough
that's just the infinite sum if you read
a beautiful mind John Nash through that
in his head but I can't but that's just
the formula okay so basically that is
the general formula for perpetuity and
that makes and that makes a life easy
will give you a lot of examples where we
you know cuz if I say I want you to pay
them for eight years in the future you
got to write out eight terms here it's a
pain in the ass so it will say is money
forever and they can just use this
shortcut which is the present value for
a perpetuity it's just F over I okay
questions about that yeah that's a great
point
yes I'm assuming constant just rate over
time now in reality you'd want to have
each periods interest rate here and then
you can't use this formula because the
interest rate itself is changing very
good point okay now the other way to
think about this is instead of thinking
just this this will be easy for most of
you but just it's useful to think it
through let's flip on his head not think
about present valueless think about
future value this is a useful tool as
well as slipping on its head okay
so let's think about the value of a
future stream of payments well by the
same logic we wrote before future value
by same watch we wrote before if you're
gonna have money that's tears in the
future the future value of that money
that you're gonna get okay if you're
gonna basically take your money and
invest it you're gonna have money that
you're gonna invest today and put it in
the bank and some interest rate then the
future value is the amount you put in
times one plus the interest rate tunity
so I've simply reversed that formula
present value future value
so basically future value if you put
money in the bank at some interest rate
you're going to get to have over time
that money times 1 plus I to the T now
the reason we write this formula and
sort of flip it for you is because I
want to highlight the key feature here
then I want to drill into your heads one
of them I don't know I guess 10 things I
most care you leave this course thinking
about if you're not gonna major in
economics but remembering is the beauty
of compounding which is that with a
formula like this you weren't interest
on your interest if you leave money in
the bank you don't just earn interest on
the initial amount you put in your an
interest on the interest you earn over
time ok and this can be quite large so
let's do a simple example ok just to
show you how big this can be to get you
all thinking about what you should do
with your money when you get a job ok
imagine you plan to work full time from
age 22 to age 70
well daunting to think about now
probably
to retire after 70 by the time you guys
retire but let's just think about 22 to
70 okay and let's say that you can save
at a constant 7% interest rate inflation
zero the interest rates constant make
life easy 7% interest rate okay and
let's consider two different plans you
have for savings plan one plan one is
that you're gonna save $3,000 a year for
the first 15 years that you work and
then stop saving 3000 0:15 is then you
just gonna leave that in the bank leave
alone never save any more just let that
money sit in the bank okay well in that
case what will you have
well after the first 15 years of putting
three thousand dollars in the bank every
year if you work out the math you will
have $75,000 75387
after 15 years okay that's now that's
not just fifteen years times that's
bigger than fifteen times 3,000 cuz
you're earning interest along the way
okay that's nice fifteen years then
you're just gonna let that sit there and
that's gonna sit there
remember after 15 years you started
working at 22 only 37 years old that's
gonna then sit there for the next 33
years you're not gonna touch it I could
save anymore
what that means is after 33 years this
turns into 75 387 times 1.07 to the 33rd
okay after 33 years or seven hundred and
three thousand dollars seven oh three oh
ten okay so you save $3,000 it's not a
lot of money you guys gonna make a lot
of money three thousand dollars for 15
years and then you never had to save
again contrast that with different
approach let's say you say look that's
stupid I'm young I'm gonna party I'll
worry about retirement retirements close
so I'm gonna save nothing the first 15
years and then I'm gonna save three
thousand dollars every year for 15 years
I'm going to save nothing then I'll save
$3,000 over year okay well if you do
that and do the math you end up with
when you retire three fifty six eight
hundred
think about this for one second
in this case you save for two more than
twice as many years you say for 33 years
and you ended up with half as much
that's the miracle of compounding the
earlier you save the more money you can
make it along the way and that's why you
guys need to start saving right away
yeah
plan 2 was I do nothing the first 15
years then I save the remaining 30 I
save $3,000 in for the mating 30 years
of my career okay so literally in
playing one I say for 15 years and then
I stop here I say for 33 years but by
starting early and using the miracle of
compounding ended put twice as much
money okay now this is actually pretty I
can act this is one of the few things in
this class my kids can understand when
they were little
because having hadn't been to Boston
Science Museum and you guys been okay if
there's a little kid area where they've
got this ramp and you can essentially
drop balls down a ramp and one ramp is
flat and then steep and one ramp is
steep and then flat and of course the
one that's steeper than flat wins it's
faster and that's just because of
compounding that's because acceleration
is compounding okay so basically the
point is that the earlier you start
saving the more money you'll have and
that's why you guys should pay attention
when you're offered a job and offer 401
K and I think retirement I'll never
retire you say no I want to save now
because the more I saved now the more
that'll compound by the time I retire
okay now you can actually see this it's
not just MIT students have to think
about this but professional athletes so
probably none of you have heard of Bobby
Bonilla any of you guys heard of Bobby
Benina no okay well if you were 25 years
ago in this class if you were to support
you order in Bobby benita he was a
pretty good player in his time and um he
retired
um he but by the end of his career he
was kind of a slacker he wasn't really
worth much he was playing for the Mets
and the Mets said look in 1999 they said
look we basically want to pay you off to
leave the team
you have a contract we're just gonna
sleep I pay the remaining 5.9 million on
your contract in 1999 give me the money
most athletes would have said great I'm
off to Vegas
Bobby buddy you didn't he said well look
I've got enough money right now but I
might need the money later
so instead why don't you defer the money
at an 8% interest rate and pay me
starting in 2011 when I'm getting close
to retirement need the money they were
like hey that's were like great we'll
have to pay you now that's great well
Bobby Bini Lea by the time his payments
are to 2011 they've grown to 30 million
dollars and every year on a certain day
just pass the reason they call Bobby
Bonilla de Bobby who's now like 7 years
old gets a 1 gets a million dollar check
from the Mets every year okay because
there's patient enough to put this off
and get the virtue of compounding okay
so this is sort of if Bobby Bonita you
know a stupid baseball player can do it
you guys can do it so make sure that you
guys are saving when you start jobs okay
questions about that okay now let's
let's let's let's get a little bit
realistic and let's recognize that in
life prices aren't constant but rather
we have inflation and how does that
affect our thinking here how does
inflation affect the way we think about
this problem well it turns out it
actually adds one step but it's actually
a pretty easy step to put in extra turns
out you can add inflation without doing
a whole lot of work so let's talk about
first what inflation is inflation is the
rise in the price level year-over-year
tackling the inflation rate is a
percentage concept it's the percent rise
in the price level year after year and
you might say the price level of what of
a banana of a computer of what well what
the government does is they form
something called the Consumer Price
Index the CPI talked about CPI yet okay
I'm sorry I just and I hate repeating
myself okay so they form something
called the Consumer Price Index
what's Tim Price Index literally the
government every quarter I believe it is
it may be every month goes out and gets
the prices of a basket of hundreds of
goods they literally say what does a
banana cost this month compared to last
month what does a laptop cost this month
compared to last month etc so they go
out and they price this bundle of goods
and then literally they just asked how
has the price that
take a weighted average of that bundle
where the weights are consumer spending
so consumers spend a lot more if their
income on housing than bananas so the
price of housing gets a lot more weight
in the CPI than as the price of bananas
essentially a weighted average of prices
in society and then that they cream
index 1982 is normalized to one and they
just say how much in percentage terms
did that weighted average bundle go up
in price okay and you can see that in
Figure 17 one here's historical CPI so
basically what you see is this is the
level of the CPI which is sort of
meaningless we care about his inflation
which is the year-to-year percentage
change in the CPI and what you can see
is basically it's going up prices are
going up it went up very steeply if you
look from 1970 to 1980 the slope there
is much higher than the slope before
after we had very rapid inflation in the
1970s it then and then since flattened
and inflation has been much slower and
inflation averaged is about three
percent a year okay
so basically that's how we measure
inflation now the question is how does
that affect our thinking about present
value if there's actually inflation and
the bottom line is we don't care about
dollars we care about how many goods we
can buy therefore it doesn't matter
what's happening to how much money we
have it matters what's happened - how
many Goods we can buy therefore what we
care about is not what we call the
nominal interest rate we care about we
call the real interest rate or which we
define as the nominal interest rate
which is well been talking about we see
advertised in a bank - the rate of
inflation which for some reason we use
PI even though that's also profits so
sorry about that okay so we define the
real interest rate as the nominal
interest rate - the inflation rate okay
the nominal and real estate nominal rate
- the inflation rate and what the real
interest rate measures is how much more
I have in time in terms of goods I can
consume not how much more I have in
terms of dollars which actually in the
end doesn't matter okay so suppose
that I'm gonna save $100 at a 10%
interest rate it's go simple example
they have $100 or 10% interest rate okay
what I then next you'll have one hundred
and ten dollars but that's irrelevant
what I want to know is how many Goods
can I buy next year so for example let's
say you spend all your money on skittles
that's all you buy okay and let's say
skittles cost $1 this year and there's
no inflation those cost $1 next year
then what that means with a 10% interest
rate is you can buy ten more bags of
Skittles next year this year your
hundred dollars could buy you a hundred
bags of Skittles next year your hundred
ten dollars can buy 110 bags of Skittles
so you are ten percent richer but now
let's say the price of skittles goes up
10 percent well what that means is you
can only buy the same amount of skittles
next year you could buy this year you
could buy a hundred bags this year and
100 bags next year so it doesn't matter
you have a hundred and ten dollars next
year who cares you can only get the same
amount of skittles what you care about
is the goods you can buy note on utility
wouldn't put dollars utility function we
put consumption so the interest rate you
care about is the real interest rate if
the nominal in straight is ten percent
but inflation is ten percent then the
real interest rate is zero you can't buy
any more Goods next year all the money
you made by putting the bank got eaten
up by how much more expensive things are
so what that means is all the math we've
done and everything we'll talk about it
all goes through you just need to be
thinking about using the real interest
rate not the nominal interest rate okay
but otherwise everything we've done is
goes through you just need to
essentially think about this in terms of
how many goods you can buy not how much
money you have now this isn't quite let
me just take two minutes and do a little
macroeconomics this isn't quite as
simple as it sounds because of course
you see in the bank I in the bank window
I you don't see pie you don't see
inflation that's what we revealed
ex-post
so really technically you don't have to
know this is just for those who care
it's just the test
technically what you really want is
expected inflation right when you think
I'm putting in the money in the bank you
know you learn 3% the realist rate is
that - what you think inflation is going
to be
right so it actually becomes complicated
it's not as simple ex-post it's easy to
find the real interest rate ex ante it's
not so easy because depends on what you
think inflation is going to be there's
some tricks there there's also a bunch
of tricks and measuring the inflation
rate so for example like I said the
Bureau of Labor Statistics goes out and
has a bundle of 600 goods it gets their
prices but what is it good I mean a
bananas a banana but a laptop what the
hell is a laptop how much RAM does it
have what's the graphics card
you know how faith is to display well
the Bureau logistics doesn't go out and
price literally hundreds of laptops at
prices one or two and the problem with
that is the following let's say you find
that today a laptop is a thousand and
tomorrow it's 1,500 but it can do let's
say today laptops a thousand and
tomorrow it's 1500 but it can do a ton
more stuff well we would say inflation
is 50% but that's not really right
because the good you're consuming is not
the laptop it's the computing ability of
the laptop and that's gone up so to say
inflation 50% is wrong inflation 50% -
the quality improvement of the better
laptop you got think of it another way
imagine laptop prices didn't go up but
RAM doubled okay would you say you're no
better off buying a laptop with twice as
much RAM at the same price no you're
better off but about our inflation
concept would say no you're the same
often so the trick here is it simple and
practice and we'll pretend as simple to
say are as I - PI but two tricks a it's
expected PI which is hard to guess and
be inflation is really hard to measure
because there's things like quality bias
and other things there's a whole field
de macroeconomics worrying about
inflation measurement so let's spend a
lot of time on it but it's just sort of
the kind of interesting we tweak just to
sort of talk about how sort of at high
level we go things here like everything
else in this class largely we get it
right largely expected inflation is not
too badly modelled by last year's
inflation and quality bias bias we can
model it stuff so this isn't a bad model
but it just sort of points to some of
the subtleties you have to deal with a
reality when you try to implement these
basic sort of formulations okay now
with that in mind I'm gonna now say
let's assume inflation zero again okay
so we'll go back and use I and we'll use
I interchangeably with our for the rest
of this course okay unless asked
differently unless told differently
assume inflation zero so INR and are
interchangeable with that in mind let's
go to the next topic which is taking
these tools how do we model choices over
time
how do people model how do people make
decisions over time and there's a simple
int so this is tricky because if I said
to you hey I'm gonna give you what do
you want $30 or $50 you'd say I want $50
but actually shouldn't say that you
should say over what period of time by
getting the 30 and over what period of
time by getting the 50 if it's today I
want 50 but then 50 is 20 years in the
future in the 30s today I might want the
30 what that means is you have to
evaluate choices in present value terms
you can't just add up the money you have
to evaluate those choices in present
value terms and then you need to pick
the option with the highest present
value so let's see let's come back to
athletes because I've let a contracts
deal with this all the time let's
imagine athlean considering two
different contracts okay contract one
pays contract a pays a million dollars
today contract be okay
pays 500,000 today and 1.5 million in
ten years okay now when you read in the
newspaper you'll see this guy got off
for a million this guy got off for two
million
that's what newspaper will say but
that's wrong because these are painted
different periods of times that are
different amounts indeed
the present value the first contract is
what 1 million dollars it's today what's
the present value the second contract
someone tell me how I'd write that down
I'd write down the present value the
second contract
exactly what you want I'll st. straight
to the 10th right because we're getting
in 10 years okay
so essentially um that means that
whether it's a better deal or not
depends on the interest rate indeed if
the interest is 7% and this rate is 7%
this has a present value of 1.3 million
so it's a good deal if the interest rate
was 14% then this deal would have a
present value of 0.9 million so it's a
worse deal so whether or not this a
better or worse deal depends on the
interest rate why is that
why is this a worse deal the higher the
interest rate yeah exactly
you could have invested it earlier got
in the compounding and had way more
money in 10 years so the higher the
interest rate the more you want to get
your money upfront and save it the less
valuable is money in the future okay now
so essentially what this says you have
to always use present value to bring
things into current dollars now this is
not an abstract concept
let's take max scherzer who's a picture
with the Washington Nationals max
scherzer um a couple years ago signed a
seven-year two hundred a seven-year two
hundred and ten million dollar contract
which he was able to brag was the
second-highest ever signed by a pitcher
and the tenth highest contract ever
signed by any baseball player seven
years to ten but in fact um that
contract was not we're gonna pay you
thirty million dollars a year for seven
years it was we're gonna pay you 15
million dollars a year for 14 years
you're gonna play him for only seven
we're gonna pay over fourteen years so
in fact in present value terms it was
worth somewhat less if you use the
current interest rate when you signed it
which is about four point seven percent
it was only worth actually 166 million
not too shabby
but suddenly drops the 20th most
valuable baseball contracting about
fourth among pitchers so Max Scherzer
was able to feel better about himself
that he signed to it you know this
valuable contract but in fact it was
worth less than he thought me shed no
tears from Max Scherzer he's doing fine
but it was worth less than he thought
or maybe one example it's more in our
mind with the Mega Millions think about
a lottery winner so if a Mega Millions
winner gets two hundred ninety million
dollars hey which sounds like a great
deal that's paid out over 20 years so
it's not two hundred ninety million
dollars it's fourteen and a half million
for each of 20 years so in present value
terms if we think about a 7% interest
rate then that's not 290 million 164
million once again not too shabby okay
but a lot less than the advertised
amount so we have to take these dollars
and put them in present value okay so
now now here's an interesting question
for that if you look at the recent
lottery okay you had a choice of the
person one person one point six billion
one person one down person in South
Carolina on that and they were given a
choice of the 1.6 billion which is paid
actually over 30 years or a lump sum
they can get right away how should they
decide which of those options to take
how should I say I wouldn't think the
1.6 billion paid over 30 years so in
physics over 30 paid in equal
installments you know over time versus
just getting a lump sum today not if one
put six million but a less at lower
amount how should they think about that
first value they should say well what do
I think Peter's rates gonna be by this
could be really low let's say the
gate-source rates going to be zero then
which deal should I take
I should spread it out over time because
the money and the futures worth the same
is today so miles take the 1.6 billion
but if I think since rates couldn't be
higher then I should take the money
upfront and invest that money and earn
my own interest
so essentially becomes a debate of how
what you think the straight is versus
what the state thinks interest rate is
they're setting those two to be equal
under some they're some assumption of
the interest rate I don't know what
number they chose whatever number they
chose it was some number they chose
because this is our assumption interest
rate you've gotta decide do you think
it's rates gonna be higher or lower
these could be higher than the state
thinks it is then you want the money up
front and you'll invest it if you need
to be lower than you should take your
money over time
and because the states giving you
basically a better deal okay people
understand that okay so now armed with
this let's go and think about how do
firms make investment decisions how do
firms make investment decisions
remember investment or investment is
about the delay of future consumption of
current consumption for future
consumptions about putting some aside
today by spending money on a machine
which will deliver you benefits in the
future now this adds one wrinkle to
we've done so far which is that we've
only talked about money that's always
positive somehow you get in the future
when you're making an investment
decision it's a little bit more
complicated because you're actually
spending money today to make money
tomorrow so in that case we talk about
we call net present value which is the
same thing it just allows for negative
values net present value which is
essentially saying in every period
you want to count for the cost that
period and the benefits that period and
you want to invest only if the net
present value is greater than zero so
for example think about a project that
has a stream of payments in every period
of R sub I every period it's got stream
of payments of R sub I and instead of
costs of C sub I the costs are the
upfront investment B the maintenance of
the machine whatever it costs to run it
okay then the net present value that
investment
is r0 minus C 0 comma r1 on a c1 over 1
plus I I'm sorry
plus over 1 plus I plus r2 minus C 2
over 1 plus I squared plus 4 as many
periods of the investment last okay
that's the net present value of an
investment so basically what you want to
ask is take each parents costs and
benefits into account on net is it
greater than 0 okay so the key point is
that basically sometimes investments
which have upfront costs can be valuable
as long as the long-run benefits are
large enough so if you think about an
investment that's got a hundred so so
imagine think about a simple trivial
example of the first period you buy a
machine and it costs um and it cost $100
so c0 is 100 and let's say for every
period thereafter that machine will
deliver your revenues revenue i revenues
for i greater than 0 of 200 but it will
have maintenance costs costs i greater
than 0 of 50 so what's the net present
value well the net present value is
simply minus 100 and let's say machine's
gonna last forever
minus 100 plus 150 over I think about
that for a second basically what we're
saying is you're throwing 100 out of
today that's negative but every period
your future going to net $150 because
you're gonna make $250 maintenance cost
and we have per formula so we just apply
the formula for perpetuity we have a set
of future payments of $150 so your net
net present value is minus 100 plus 150
over I so let's think about
look at this formula for a second what
does that say what is the relationship
between whether the firm's gonna want to
invest and the interest rate what does
this imply the relationship between
firms desire for investment and the
interest rate as the interest rate goes
up
well firms want to do more investment or
less investment in Y well firms want to
be more eager to buy machines or
lessening to buy machines and why and
straight goes up yeah let's see here
less eager State again because why I
think it easier thing is borrowing just
think about they got a bunch of money
Apple's got a bunch of money today
they're sitting on if they buy the
Machine they're going to get this return
if they don't buy the Machine they can
put it in the bank or invest in Apple
stock and get some interest rate I the
higher the alternative the higher the
interest rate the less they want invest
or think of it this way the interest
rate is the opportunity cost of
investment okay the more the firm
invests in their machines the less they
can earn saving through some other
mechanism and the price that they pay by
forgoing that other savings is I okay
yeah basically you always want to try to
make as much money as you can and make
the cost as late as you can for any
given amount you'd absolutely like to
shift your you'd actually like
absolutely like to do that
that's why we'll talk about this in my
in my public finance class we talked
about why when you're paying taxes you
always want to try to find shenanigans
allow you to pay your taxes later so for
any given tax until later you pay it the
more cost the less it cost you because
you get to earn the interest along the
way and then pay it with after it and
pay it later on this is a key
macroeconomic concept you'll often hear
in the news high interest rates are bad
for business and you might have thought
why is that this is why hunt rates are
bad for the economy you'll hear why are
high streets bad for the economy you
might say wasted that makes no sense my
interest rate means I earn more on my
savings why is that bad for the economy
it's bad for the economy because it
lowers the demand for capital because
the higher
the interest rate the less firms
actually want to invest the more they
just want to stock their money away in
the bank okay so that is kind of um
that's the key that's the key question
now then let me ask another question if
you're a firm what's the right eye to
use if you're a firm think about this
investment we know the higher I is the
less you want to invest but what is I
once again forget inflation inflation
zero what's the right what we call firm
discount rate the discount rate is the
amount by which firms are going to
discount future dollars to bring them
back today how does the firm think about
what I to use what I should the firm use
your Apple yeah they don't want invest
unless it's positive that's a good point
but but but but the way they do is they
write down the method may plug in and I
what I do they plug in yeah well I might
be but it's not there's not one answer
what's the general answer the firm wants
to use what's the general answer that
the firm if you're a firm thinking about
in vacant investment you want to
discount that investment what do you
want to discount it by yeah the next
best thing you could do so if I'm
thinking about building this machine
when I discount I wanna think about
what's the next best thing I could do
with that money
that's the discount rate I want to use
so in a world where firms either
couldn't buy a machine or put it in the
bank it's easy it's the bank interest
rate but life's not that easy firms have
dozens of investments so where every
investment you want to discount it by
the next best thing you can do with the
money concept of opportunity cost that's
why it's a very first thing we taught in
this class opportunity cost is always
what drives things okay questions about
that now this isn't just for firms this
same math applies to consumers as well
let's think about me a number of years
ago I had to decide whether to insulate
my ancient house
okay let's write down the numbers to
sort of think how this worked
I had heating bills at that time back
when gas was cheaper of about two
thousand dollars a year
where's my heating bills for the house
okay the best estimate I could get was
it if I insulated my house I would lower
my heating costs by 25%
so my heating costs would fall by $500
per year if isolated my cost if isolated
my house and the insulation but to
inflate my house I had to pay the guy to
insulate it and that cost the insulation
cost $4,000 how do I think about whether
they should insulate or not how do I
think about that decision what equation
should I write down yeah I should say
I'll assume I'm gonna own the house
forever or at least long enough that I
can treat it as forever
and I write down that formula and what
that formula says is that if I think in
shrinks less than 12.5% I should
insulate if I think pH rate is more than
12.5% I should just invest the money and
use the use of returns that investment
to pay my higher heating bills so it all
depends on what the interest rate is
okay now so that's why and I did it I
insulated but that's exactly so the same
logic we could think of is is basically
essentially the same ideas firms you
want think about the upfront costs and
the long-run returns okay
here's a funny economics question what
if I don't intend to hold the house
forever I would argue I should still use
this formula why yeah
exactly because I'm increasing the value
of an asset that I'll then sell so
presume by insulating I've raised the
price of my house how much I raised it
by exactly five hundred of her eyes so
I'm gonna insulate and sell next year I
should still insulate because I should
get five hundred of RI more dollars for
my house so in fact it doesn't matter if
you can sell an asset then actually your
pur isin is always infinite it's not
just the short horizon which is kind of
interesting insight okay so the last
thing I want to talk about is the fact
that these decisions are not just
relevant you guys are like retirement
business machines insulation guide your
old John I don't care about any of this
stuff well let's hear what something you
care about which is going to college
let's talk about your decision you've
already made it but you've got a little
sibling and they're deciding whether to
go to college
okay well let's and and and they're not
going to go to MIT they're gonna go to a
more typical school and they've got to
decide whether go to college well in
fact their decision is an investment
decision just like any other investment
decision what they're investing in is
what we call their human capital when
you get education you're investing in
yourself just like you invest in a
machine because you are you hope raising
the value of what you can do of what you
can earn by investing in learning stuff
well that human capital investment has
the same features of any other
investment there's an opportunity cost
which is what what's the opportunity
cost of investing your time and going to
come what's the opportunity cost of
going to college yeah you could this to
one is you can get a job you could not
pay tuition so if you think about going
to college you're sacrificing two things
you all that money you're paying you
could basically invest instead of giving
it to some college and you can be a
burning money instead of sitting here
listening to me okay so if you think
about that um you actually it actually
becomes a hard decision you might think
so let's think about a simple example
let's imagine that if you don't go to
you work from age 18 to 70 and if you do
go to college work from age 22 to 70
sorry ignore grad school okay four years
of college either start working in 18
and start working at 22 and let's say
college cost $35,000 a year obviously
not MIT okay let's say college cost
$35,000 a year okay and let's say that
if you worked
you could have let's say that if you
worked while you were if you worked
starting in high school you could have
earned
um actually Patricia we don't have the
yeah you could have earned $20,000 you
could have earned $20,000 if you'd if
you you could have started at $20,000
you've gone to work at age 18 okay well
we can actually graph what this looks
like in Figure 17 - 17 - if you think
about age 18 from age 18 to age 22
that's the green area if you go to
college you give up the $35,000 in
tuition and the 20k you could have
earned the bottom line is basically the
red line is your lifetime earnings if
you go to high school if you if you
don't go to college the great the green
line is your lifetime earnings the blue
line I'm sorry is your lifetime earnings
if you go to college empirical estimates
suggests at age 22 the typical college
graduate earns $45,000 yes you're not
the typical college graduate the typical
college graduates $45,000 and the
typical highschool non-college educators
are seven it's $28,000 so at age 22 you
come out of college or any 45 and if
you'd not gone to college we're in 28
not you but a normal person okay but
moreover knowledge you learn more when
you leave college your earnings grows
faster so if you're college-educated not
only means you earn 17 K more at 22 it
also means your earnings grows faster so
that by age 51 the
average at college educated person earns
$80,000 while the average high school
person earns $45,000 so what you see
here is the blue line starts above the
red line okay and maybe I would learn to
clip this on a fight and gone to college
okay so the gap widens over time so how
do we think about this decision well the
cost is the green area the cost is over
four years you could have earned money
and you wouldn't had to pay tuition the
benefit is the yellow area over that
entire time after graduation you're
making more money now obviously in terms
of size the yellow area is much much
bigger than the green area but the
yellow area comes later that's the key
thing she might look and say look it's
obvious you get before this lecture you
might say well it's obvious you go to
college look the yellows way bigger than
the green but that's not necessarily
true cuz the green comes now and the
yellow comes later indeed if you look at
the table this actually shows the net
present value on a college in high
school and what this shows is at low
interest rates you're much better off
going to college so if there's no
interest rate okay then college is a
much much better deal your net present
value of earnings if you go to you're
never that I go to college is 2.6
million we're only 1.6 million if you
don't go to college but once the
interest rate gets above 8% it suddenly
becomes a worse deal to go to college
that is that only a 9% interest rate
which existed not that long ago okay in
our history it was actually a worse deal
for to average person to go to college
yeah well actually it's interesting it
depends the poor financial aid why
someone tell me why it's depend in the
form of financial aid it actually comes
in different forms so why is it depend
on how you get the financial aid yeah if
it's a life if it's a grant then yeah
you should just take that out of the
cost but if it's a loan depends what it
straight you get the loan act if the low
is that the market interest rate then
it's no different right
but that's a great point which is why
college financial aid comes in two forms
grants for very low income people and
low-interest loans for other people why
do we give loan which loans for college
because of this graph because we're
saying we want to we think people need
to invest in their education we're
afraid that if they face the regular
interest rate they won't be willing to
do it because the green that would
bigger than the yellow so actually gonna
subsidize their loan their interest rate
so that's you might have thought to
yourself sort of a weird way to get
people to go to college is to have a
lower student loan interest rate but in
fact it makes perfect sense
by having a student loan interest rate
that's lower than the market rate you
encourage people to go to college
because essentially you lower this
discount rate for at least at least on
the part that's tuition payments okay so
that's actually a very exciting um we
need to think about in a very important
part of public policy it's how we set
the interest rate on student loans for
any of you how many you guys have a
student loan do you know and you gather
student loan you might not know anyway I
set the interest rate in that student
loan so thank you actually when I was in
the government I wasn't gone for
fourteen months the Clinton
administration it was super fun but
looking back I only got one thing done
which I got to set things straight in
student loans so that was kind of fun uh
but otherwise I it was just a lot of fun
being there so so anyway uh let's stop
there and we will we will continue uh
let's say with it so no class on Monday
that's Veterans Day so we'll meet in a
week next Wednesday